لدينا جميعًا القدرة على أن نكون مبدعين ،
فنحن جميعًا مدفوعون لمشاركة أعمق
أحلامنا وأفكارنا مع العالم عندما
نفكر في الأشخاص المبدعين الموهوبين
الذين يتحدثون إلينا بطريقة فريدة من نوعها ،
وهي عبارة نسمعها غالبًا هي
امتلاك صوت إبداعي  لكنني أصبت
بسرطان الحلق ،
اسمي مال كيلمر وأنا هنا
لأنني
أؤدي الليلة في القرن ،
لدي آلاف الساعات من أشرطة الفيديو
وبكرات الأفلام التي قمت بتصويرها طوال
حياتي وحياتي المهنية وأغلق كاميرا الفيديو.
استمر في تشغيله حتى الرجوع للخلف
بعد أن أتعامل مع
صوتي لأنني أعلم أنه قد سلب
مني
الناس من حولي يكافحون لفهمي
عندما أتحدث عن
[موسيقى] ،
استمع إلى الرياضة وحدد معجبي توك
إذا أعجبك ما تراه
فقط انتظر حتى يأتي
[موسيقى
] التالي ، كنت أشاهد غروب الشمس
فوق الصحراء ، ما أفعله هنا
أعتقد أنه كان لدينا ما يقرب من 20000
ساعة من اللقطات لننتقل إليها من خلال
[موسيقى]